[Music]
well when I was growing up I was born
from immigrants and Irish and Lebanese
and Irish father Lily's mother and by
the time I hit seven it was clear I had
some really big problems in math and
reading going back to the education
because I had a really bad case of
dyslexia and so in those days dyslexic
you know outcomes were bad because you
would really fell behind in school and
they didn't really understand how it
worked and luckily I was very fortunate
my mother was desperate she was trying
to find a solution for this because I
was falling behind really quickly in
those critical years in in early school
and so she found this woman named
Marjorie garlic who had an experimental
Sam Rabinowitz and Marjorie Gulliver
researchers they're published all around
the world now but they basically thought
they could take dyslexic children after
school maybe 12 or 18 and put them into
an experimental program where they try
and convince the kids that dyslexia is
actually a superpower that other people
don't have so that your confidence
really advances and that's that's what
they ended up doing with me they said
look do you know anybody else in your
class that can read a book upside down
in a mirror no you're the only guy that
can do it that's power they wish they
could do it they can't and so that
started give me the confidence because
this Lexi doesn't really [ __ ] learning
it just makes the mean the incumbant
tools in schools useless to you I mean
nobody gives you a book upside down in a
mirror you have to learn how to deal
with what dyslexia does and that once I
had that solved it was a very
interesting acceleration that occurred
and you find in business today all kinds
of founders of companies like the guy
that found in JetBlue a really bad case
of dyslexia I think it it helps you
think outside of the box and I've always
thought business is half creativity that
comes from the chaos of the arts and
half the discipline of science business
is binary you either make money or lose
it I think great CEOs great
entrepreneurs combined the chaos of art
with a discipline of science and and I
believe that to be the case and I look
for that and the people invest in now
and I think that dyslexic
you know chaos for me was was a pivotal
point
catalyst that I could build so my you
know direction off subscribe to my
channel you know what happens you'll be
dead to me
[Music]
[Applause]